since it invaded ukraine russia has
become increasingly isolated from the
rest of the world one of its few
remaining allies is the authoritarian
leadership of belarus however its
smaller neighbor is paying a price for
its role in putin's war vladimir putin
has been tightening his hold over
belarus and its autocratic leader
alexander lukashenka and with the two
countries targeted by sanctions over the
ukraine war russian dominance is only
set to grow
last fall putin and luka shenka agreed
on a 28-point economic cooperation plan
it includes a common monetary policy and
energy market but in this partnership
russia is firmly in the driver's seat
around 45 of all goods exported by
belarus in 2020 went to russia
it's a similar story for imports half
came from russia primarily raw materials
belarus is dependent on russian oil and
gas and the two nations hope to
establish a common energy market by
2023.
belarus is already a member of moscow's
eurasian economic union that's a trading
block aimed at increasing russian
influence over former soviet countries
now let's speak to lev levovovsky who is
a senior research fellow at the economic
think tank barak he's from belarus but
barack has actually recently had to move
from ukraine to batumi in georgia
because of the war and he joins us from
there thanks a lot for being with us on
dw business can you just explain to us
is the ultimate aim
for belarus to be absorbed
into russia
uh hello
well the thing is that uh after
alexander lukashenka lost elections in
2020
he had to make
several steps each one of them was
basically trading sovereignty
of belarus for russian support
uh the reason is that
the only or the last international
friend of israel kashanka is president
of russia vladimir putin
and therefore it looks like that
alexander
does not have
any other options
so does this
ever closer union between russia and
belarus
is that something that's welcomed by
bella russians
no i don't think so
most of belarusians actually
want to live
in a separate country
although at least before the war uh the
general attitude towards russians
were rather positive but still the
russians always wanted to live in a
separate country
belarus is also being targeted with
sanctions for its part in the invasion
of ukraine and what sort of impact are
those sanctions having
well impact
is
very very negative uh the only thing
that we don't know is
we would be bad or we would be horrible
the thing is that belarus is a small and
open economy so we depend on import and
expert a lot
as you know
there is pretty much no countries in the
world which
live in waterkey except probably north
korea
so in most of belarus production we use
inputs which are imported
and we heavily depend on experts even
worse
our
uh one of one of our most important
trade partners is ukraine and now
since attacks on ukraine are made
also from the territory of belarus
we will probably lose this
line of experts for
years and is belarus therefore in really
an impossible position because not only
does it still need to trade with
the rest of europe and would like to
with ukraine but also lukashenko wants
to stay close to vladimir putin i mean
what are the options does belarus just
have to suffer the sanctions
unfortunately i think so the thing is
that of course it is very easy
technically for belarus to get rid of
sanctions belarus just has to be a
neutral uh has to stop russia from using
his territory to attack ukraine
to bring tanks which then go to kiev
but it looks like that alexander
lukashenko
cannot tell vladimir putin that
belarus will actually be neutral uh he
is trying to confirm this russian
neutrality to other parties
uh he proposes uh belarus to be a place
where peace talks can happen
even more these peace talks actually
started on the russian soil
but nevertheless nobody really believes
that belarus is a neutral country it is
clearly documented that attacks go from
the russian soil
uh and that also
basically is losing his power over this
territory
of course
if
he will
be brave enough he can stop it at any
moment
but then probably he will lose power
inside
because
of his
unpopularity i can remind you that he
lost a popular vote in 2020
and pretty much everything that is
happening now
is because of his struggle for power
yeah so lukachenko's power is dependent
on putin to some extent well lev
levovovsky from barrock thank you so
much for joining us on dw business
you